well it is a much different site this is
bourbon street
on mardi gras this year can you believe
this just see it looks like two police
officers
wow live look uh it is about nine
o'clock there this morning yeah there's
some decorations there
fat tuesday mardi gras means the end of
carnival season which began back in
january and they live it up before
lent begins tomorrow a period of fasting
and reflection ahead of easter nate
all right well of course bars in the big
easy shut down over the weekend it's
going to be closed through
early tomorrow morning all because they
want to make sure that the coronavirus
doesn't spread
you know we've got lots of video of
years past where things go crazy down
there but bar owners say they're a
little bit split
when it comes to not letting the good
times roll
the main thing is that it is not going
to change any of the dynamics during
mardi gras it's going to
make a change on who makes money and who
does it people else will be making the
money that we should be making
we know that if we stay open during
mardi gras
to expect a spike that is going to shut
us down
we're going to be closed for weeks after
the economics of it don't make sense
either
you know everybody's had to sacrifice
and this is a big one i'm sure for the
big easy
while people won't be living it up on
bourbon street people in new orleans
have created a new mardi gras tradition
now
since all of their big parades were
canceled people decided to decorate
their homes instead so it's being dubbed
yardygra
this year this all began as a joke
really on social media but
now some 3 000 homes are decorated as
part of a drive-by porch parade
whenever he gets older i want to look
back and show him how mardi gras was in
quarantine
we actually hope that this is a thing
every year even when the parades come
back
new orleans is going to have a good time
no matter what
they will so to help the community some
of the homeowners hired unemployed
artists and rented props from struggling
parade float
company so that was the right thing to
do i've
been in new orleans once and a friend of
mine who lives there took me into one of
the big warehouses where they built a
chunk of those
floats it's such an extravagant
community effort to build those things
it's amazing to see
so it's nice to see they're putting them
in people's yards instead just because
that's what you got to do alex
yeah it's just so weird to see bourbon
street like that but you know nate they
got the beads
on the houses and that shot of bourbon
street looks like
bourbon street normally looks tomorrow
morning the day after
where you might see something minus the
trash exactly stumbling down the street
would be about it